slow roll this morning yeah yeah yeah
just get into the stringy things you
have to laughing horses had their
[Laughter]
different views in your already go back
response you might be my favorite human
being I hope I did oh my god god yeah
all you have that on video you put your
[ __ ] head phones on and snapped into
your [ __ ] face the audio that Travis
I was because I'm like well here's what
happened boss took his hat on burger
started laughing because his hair is a
total mess then his first laughing
because Russ has had here mas goes to
reapply his headphones to his newly
beheaded head and stretches them to fit
over his head and snaps right back in
today where we were worried videoing
that we were that cameras always on but
oh let on Troy I see that red light
[ __ ] yeah boy oh you panic for a second
Froy of course just you make it like
holy [ __ ] if I miss that train here it
Travis you have the audio of that event
shirt and whatever you said to be Travis
I didn't hear you I was going to say the
birth timeline on Twitter was active all
night so I don't think it got much sleep
oh okay alright let's listen let's
listen to this thing and then I would
like to attend first Twitter at channel
you have tried you laughing everyone's
had their
oh you have one more sound Robinson 20
laughing it wasn't sad there
[Laughter]